welcome back florida governor ron
desantis
blasting critical race theory and
banning it from the new statewide civics
curriculum desantis echoing former
president trump when making that
announcement
yesterday our schools are supposed to
give people a foundation of knowledge
not supposed to be indoctrination
centers where you're trying to push
specific ideologies let me be clear
there's no room
in our classrooms for things like
critical race theory
teaching kids to hate their country and
to hate each other
is not worth one red cent of taxpayer
money
joining me right now is former white
house chief of staff mark meadows mark
is great to see you tonight thanks for
being here
it's great to be with you maria you know
governor desantis was exactly right
it was right to call it out bravo to him
i hope a number of other governors
follow suit but
as he mentioned it was president trump
that actually led this particular effort
when this indoctrination was introduced
at the department of defense
president trump at that time said we're
going to have none of it
and the american hard-working american
taxpayer dollar shouldn't be uh
spent on that and really it should be
about uh
telling the great story of the founding
of this great country and uh
and what did we see joe biden do
immediately he ended the 1776 uh
commission
because it had it dared to talk about
the founding of this great country
i was absolutely extraordinary a friend
of mine sent me a memo
from her son's ninth and tenth grade
class where the teacher said
if you identify as white come to a
meeting so that we could make sure that
you can
strive not to be a racist i mean it's
absolutely extraordinary
and outrageous that these teachers are
assuming our kids
are racist racists even before they
murmur a word
and then there's another report saying
we shouldn't call people mom and dad
because it makes other people feel
uncomfortable i mean
what where is this coming from well i
mean where
where we've where is it coming from it's
coming from the progressive
left and from from those that really
have an agenda that is
is really not about america's greatness
or the fact that we can live
uh what many of us call the american
dream i grew up with humble beginnings
and
and being able to uh live the american
dream and ultimately be a success
those are the kind of things those are
the freedoms that we have in this
country instead of celebrating those
uh we're we're looking at indoctrinating
our children and
and i can tell you that uh it's it's
classrooms when you have
the ideological bent uh that is being
suggested
not just in florida but in a number of
classrooms throughout our country
that we have to finally look at common
sense and say enough is enough
we're not going to actually indoctrinate
uh
the future generation well i'm glad you
mentioned that because i
completely agree i also have lived the
american dream because my parents have
lived the american dream
i've watched them work incredibly hard
after my ancestors came here in the
early 1900s which i'm going to talk
about
tomorrow night but let me turn to the
spending
and tax proposals coming out of this
administration
you worked i know very hard with nancy
pelosi with steven mnuchin
on doing the last stimulus now we just
passed
this 1.9 trillion dollar massive
spending package
we are expecting the administration to
raise taxes significantly
in order to pay for all of this your
reaction to what we've seen
in terms of the impact that is to come
on the economy and people's lives and
their jobs
well this is a job killer this is not
something that's going to save jobs as
you mentioned
you covered it extremely well over the
last uh
12 months as we've looked to try to
provide the safety net that's there for
our economy
and for those that have struggled during
this pandemic but this 1.9 trillion
dollar uh
package uh with less than 10 percent of
it actually going to those
that are affected by uh directly by
covet 19
uh is is nothing more than a progressive
left
special interest bill and here's what
it's going to do it's going to make sure
that taxes go up
unemployment goes up and ultimately
harms the american people and
tucked inside of it is actually uh you
know governors on there
to make sure that some of the states
that actually have managed this better
are not treated as fairly as uh as new
york and california
it's a special uh bailout to the
the blue states that have done the
poorest job of keeping people employed
well that's right there was a deficit in
san francisco that's gone there was a
deficit
in new york that hole in the budget is
likely gone
because of all of the tens of billions
of dollars that they're going to get
and use to plug those holes i know
you've been working behind the scenes
with some of these attorneys generals
that are pushing back
we just heard from the arkansas ag we
spoke with ken paxton from texas earlier
in the week
what can you tell us about this effort
on the part of the ag's and the
governors to push back on this agenda
mark
well i can tell you they're working very
hard and a real shout out to
all the republican attorney generals who
not only are trying to make sure that
they keep
whether it's illegal immigration whether
it's the the issues that we're talking
about with the coveted relief
uh or some of the other uh leftist uh
ideas that are are coming in uh
they are at the front line and and help
is on the way i can tell you that they
have some of the hardest jobs working
behind the scenes
with our republican attorney generals is
going to make a difference in
in the months and weeks to come all
right well we'll be watching their
efforts for sure and cover it mark it's
great to see you this
evening thanks very much